what's happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John hump
last week we were editing that sketch a
real reject sketch we'll hope that you
guys go check that video out cameo from
a very old reject in there you guys want
me keep a lookout for it but getting
back up to a regular schedule this week
or just a reaction channel aren't we
that's all we are hey guys let's do a
video reaction to a channel that we get
along with pretty well arts mere
entertainment their tune sandwich
Jurassic world falling Kingdom trailer
spoof favorite movie of the year
pretty strong opinions about this film
people before we do that I want to get a
page from the day shout out for Erica
Tuesday Erica my darling dears you thank
you for letting me swim in your pool
you almost came to our live event oh
yeah thank you to everyone who came to
our live event by the way I forgot to
mention that that was a great success
great success
Erica Tuesday you are one fantastic
human being a good-looking gal with a
body to die for and a booty that makes
me go not worthy is that rhyme I try
making it run I'm sorry anyway this is
an animated video
Erica's an artist you can go check out
her Facebook page look at a few of these
photos that we have right here look how
much of a wonderful artist she is go
like her Facebook page she's been a
longtime supporter of this channel and
she's also a great friend of John's and
she's a person who is a friend of mine
as well
not as close her fault not mine anyway
let's watch this video let's do it uno
dos tres
[Music]
she's of course they gave in the pool
dose you were standing right next to her
when I did it I actually remember seeing
the needle go in although I have to
admit my dear did it again good night
oh there's a t-rex in here large don't I
know why we're here
rescue op to save the dinosaur you
raised her
[Music]
I nursed her whoa no I can honestly say
I have never forgotten about that heart
is actually I don't know why I did nurse
her on both sides though that was a
mistake
I don't know why you didn't use the
formula maybe that was the mistake wait
breast is bestest yeah although I am not
ashamed to feed in public Hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I think I'm just gonna drown
yeah don't worry about me come on Stuart
[Music]
this is the most dangerous creature that
ever walked the earth we call it a human
being
[Music]
that brought that path he's right we do
have this room booked and these two do
certainly subscribe to the channel
because subscribers
[Music]
I do believe you're supposed to be in
bed sounds like a raptor from Indonesia
I wanted them to call it the raptorial
Vig when we got here dormers came active
after we chose a subway through the
center of it Owen yeah you are this
franchise depends on you being idiots is
franchise Dustin ironic now depends on
idiocy to keep it alive discredit yeah I
didn't move been out for a while Mike
going to some spoiler territory here so
if you've already clicked off the video
like most of you have aha I suppose some
stuff who knows I like that gag in the
beginning of the eyeball it was a great
guy really caught me by surprise like a
simple gag that catches you off-guard
like that
yeah like simple gags like the milking
of Pratt's nipple I don't know what that
was I feel like there are a husband and
wife duo and I think the husband came up
with that are they a husband and wife do
do they have the same last name
no they just must be friends or you know
f buddies job our areata Artman or maybe
there's our stage names there yeah yeah
either way you guys should be dating at
this point you guys should be hooking up
with each other I'm just letting you
guys know that well maybe that's their
bed right behind them that breastfeeding
big mill was about the weirdest most
unsettling thing I've seen in an art
Speer video oh he's so far easily that
was a strange bit too just kept on going
and they really made it a part of their
story in this trailer smooth really
grossing me out I think what he does
right that was great if that sounds like
Chris Pratt and he's got the personality
down of Chris Pratt as well hey easy oh
yeah you know they've been like there's
star-lord jokes before but they really
got the Chris Pratt doing oh anything
down really well donations yeah yeah
that's not too far off yeah well I mean
that the whole debate sequence of the
movie where he's deciding whether or not
to
on the adventure like this is almost
more exposition than that was yeah just
goes home watches a video and there's
like you know what I changed my mind
yeah it's pretty similar to the actual
film and they just making fun of the
bits you know like we're he's graduating
putting him on a bicycle I feel like
what the way Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom ended though it's on the path to
getting there I was telling my
girlfriend the other day so the other
day that I want the Jurassic world 3 to
just go all out with how dinosaurs have
adapted to our world I don't want it to
be humans vs dinosaurs things I want
them to be pets
I want the militarization and be in
there I want t-rex's with guns we're
gonna skip past all the interesting
stuff for part 3 and right to the first
scene where Owen is teaching everyone
how to Raptor train yeah I want Raptor
is talking you need a kid in all these
your se Park movies I'm gonna main
subplots to be a raptor student is going
to school and then all the other kids
are bullying the Raptor and the main kid
befriends the Raptor but then the Raptor
snaps after too much bullying causes
harm both the humans provoked them I
think that should be the main plot you
just kind of go all around with the
Raptors being more like humans
that'll be a fantastic film and the end
when the Raptor decides not to have the
fight and grows as a character the t-rex
can show up and eat the guy who's gonna
fight yeah and save the day there are
some jokes they made in here that kind
of feel like Jurassic world could pull
it off part three you know with the
Raptor surfing yeah sure why not this
point like yeah I totally buy that in a
dress world by moving franchise has
become why not let's go down that path I
don't care I think at this point they
should get the trailer spoof guys to do
this the tuna sandwich dudes to make
dress a world 3 or at least get some
co-writing credit in there yeah because
you've ate the humor elevate the
suspension disbelief oh my gosh yeah
it's got a good franchise this is we're
watching this going I get what they're
doing I could also see the movies going
down this path yeah hey I mean you know
I think Jurassic world 3 could use a
little shot of absurdity maybe we can
just make it an absurdist piece overall
yeah
anyway toon sandwich you guys did a
great job again I want to see your
trailer spoof of an
the wasp I hope you're working on that
and dude I hope you got a great Paul
Rudd impression you better have a good
one guys you can subscribe it soon
sandwich you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification about the
subscribe button suck and you can check
us out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patreon jack
today and check out our sketch put a lot
of hard work into it about a week's
worth of time